[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
William Dominique Monahan we have
returned to the Friendship onion stage
anything to report are you comfortable
there financially no just uh just like
your bum and your legs yeah these are
comfy chairs it's nice on your back I
enjoyed this pose I don't would this be
a yogic pose where like a flamingo
almost I wonder if that's good or bad
for your hips don't know but I like it
it makes me feel quite comfy you like
that pose which I call the uh Michael
Corleone pose because at the end of The
Godfather
he just sits in his chair like who's
gonna mess with me now
Frodo yeah I think he's right here I'm
going to kick my shoes off though yeah
kick him off
peeling The Onion
hey should we fire right into a bunch of
questions because we've got a fantastic
guest yeah and we're not gonna have a
bunch of time but I'm going to jump
right into a question here
housekeeping so much
hey a message here from the lovely
Deanna in the northern Chicago suburbs
very specific probably likes him a lot a
lot indeed who said I read an article
the other day about all the times people
ugly cry when watching TV shows and
Dom's not Penny's boat moment was on the
list I should think so too it got me
thinking about all the times I've ugly
Cried by watching Lord of the Rings
which was essentially the entire ending
of Return of the King which goes on for
a long time are there any times you can
remember ugly crying while watching a TV
show or movie and if so can you tell us
about your experience I'll tell you
right now Billy boy does not cried since
he was probably eight years old
something like that he's a man of a
stone emotional Heart of Stone I was
crying I was in the I was in this Cinema
myself wasn't in the theater
watching a Maverick Top Gun oh you're in
tears man I was weeping on
what was it was there some was it warmer
was it Goose goose there was there was a
couple of times
oh my dom and I was enjoying the crying
yeah of course I enjoy a good craft
because it was a dark room and there was
hardly anyone in there and it was quite
cathartic to be honest I just I just let
it go always let it go yeah and your
bowels as well no oh just just the
crying sometimes I think sometimes I
think I think I need to cry so then yeah
so then I have to put on a movie because
it's hard for me to cry in real life but
I can really get myself there with films
E.T
it's a French film about a little girl
she's probably five and unfortunately
both her parents are brown bread
and it's you see a little dad already
doesn't try a deal with that it's an
amazing performance by this little
French girl beautiful
any other sad films at the top of your
list still Magnolias
yeah I'd steal Magnolia's with you with
you no the movie oh never seen it oh sad
is it sad On Golden Pond I always
thought it was very sad not seen that
uh well there's a few actually isn't it
you and I went to see up and that was
crazy crying so hard that you said to me
are you okay I thought you were ready
like that I know it was awful yeah and
you went over and went will you shut up
you're ruining the film for my wife and
I well I always try to eat my M M's well
I think we've covered that well I am
what we've got a another message here
from Callan and Jackie do I read that
one yeah where do you hear that stuff my
wife and I watch uh the Friendship onion
every week always with a cup of tea
we're curious to know how you take your
tea for instance one whereas your
steeping method loose leaf are in the
bag two which your favorite flavors
three what's your preferred time a day
for tea or as it with particular meals
well that's good good question two
questions on well
on you go let us know well I've got a
lot I've got a lot of tea in a few
different ways I've got a lot to say
about tea tea for me is almost always
what we call Builders tea for me yeah
which is like your Thai uh PG tips or
your Thai food thai food yeah just just
uh yeah black tea
and I have that it's got to be boiling
water I hate we would never take a cup
of tea on a flight because it's never
boiling water it's warm it's hot so it's
got a head on it it's got a little kind
of no scum scum so it has to be boiling
right off the boil enter the bag
leave that let that steep for a couple
of minutes
and then get the bag out stick the milk
in do it a little stir before you take
the bag out a little stir a little stir
up give it a squeeze oh squeezy and then
that's my tea ready and um I would say
98 of my time that's a tea I drink and
uh uh my wife used to laugh because she
said when she first met me she couldn't
believe how much tea I drank I probably
drunk 10 of those a day wow but now I'll
maybe have one a day maybe two in the
morning is it no coffee in the morning
later on I'll tell you what I love it
with done wait do you hear this
sandwich white bread banana a banana
sandwich just that and a cup of tea
is it just simply bananas are you is the
butter on that bread there's no butter
it's simply banana and it can't be too
black banana and it can't be too green
yeah it has to be perfect yeah and then
with a nice cup of tea
and I'll put on the TV so a nice
yourself put your feet up
there's nothing better Tom is that right
this is good as as a 10 minutes can be
yeah no I'm already on that one
for the past I would say probably a year
or so in the morning I've been drinking
matcha which is which is green tea
powder yeah super yummy and the the
whole method of that can't can't be
boiling no you know if you if you put
boiling water on matcha it makes it very
bitter well What temperature would you
say well you very kindly when you stayed
at my house one time when I wasn't there
bought me the greatest Kettle yeah ever
which has I think six different uh water
settings so all the way up to black tea
yep boiling yeah and all the way down to
green tea which I think is closer to
like 77 78 degrees Celsius so nowhere
near boiling no nowhere near it so a
little bit closer to our new long yeah
like an oolong exactly sit down I can
flavor so a little bit of the powder
Stir It Up with some cold water to get
the powder you know in into more of a a
liquid and then you put the warm water
on there and I sit there a little
meditation in the morning but if I'm
having your type of tea your Builders
too yeah I'm probably about the same as
you
boiling hot water leave it in there for
a minute a minute and a half without
touching it at all nice little vigorous
to take it out
milk done and I like that
with a fry up
fry up no that's nice fried eggs fried
fried bread beans mushrooms tomato and a
nice coffee somewhere it's great with
the fry up because I think sometimes
that some sometimes the stuff in a fry
can be a little tough on the stomach and
if you've got a Milky kind of tea in
there all good have we answered
everything I think we haven't that was
quite good that don't take them all
right in the mood yeah do you know what
I could go a fish tea fish chips white
bread with butter a nice cup of tea have
you found a chippy uh near where you
live I found one actually the other day
there and there's a New Zealand Chip
he's just opened near us wow not too
near but near enough that I could jump
in the car and go and get some fish and
chips treat yourself because you like a
chip you know how would you say that in
a New Zealand accent fashion chips very
good that was good that though hey
should we do a few voicemails Johnny
over there Johnny on the spot
well we're waiting for the uh voice
voicemails do you want to have a tongue
twister why not how are you feeling I
feel great tongue very um dexterous this
morning Mara from Florida Tampa Florida
sent us one well how does that go down
well am I doing it first what would you
think yeah I'll go you want to get
through it one slowly so that we know
what it is yeah there's one on the
second page as well there's one line on
the second page here we go okay Mrs
puggy wuggy has a square cut punt not a
punt cut Square just a square cut punt
it's round in the stern and blunt in the
front Mrs puggy wuggy has a square cut
punt I did it you try it Mrs pagiwagi
has a square cut punt not a punt cut
Square
just a square cut punt it's round in the
stern and blunt in the front Mrs puggy
wuggy has a square cut punt perfect
we've nailed it hey if we got a
voicemail you don't want to go faster I
think you guys could probably do this a
lot faster I'm gonna go a little bit
faster ready
Mrs puggy wuggy has a square cut punt
not a punt cut Square just a square cut
punt it's round in the stern and a
sponge in the front Mrs bucket buggy
I'm going to go that fast go Mrs pocket
well it has a square cut punt not a punt
cut square but a square cut punt it's
Randomness there and it's blunt in the
front Mrs puggy has a square cut punch
nailed it oh I know a guy who was in a
play I don't know if I've told you how
to stop I know this story but it's a
good hey he's he's in a play and he's uh
an older actors in it and his his first
entrance it comes on and the young actor
says to him where have you been all day
and he says Ah I've been hunting
I've been out in Kenny's punt
yes and he they did us all through
rehearsals the day before they opened
the young actor says I wouldn't want to
have your first line he says what do you
mean he says well you know if you get
that mixed up out in Kenny's punt I've
spent all day out in Kenny's punt yeah
what do you mean if you switch that
round that would be pennies you know and
the old dad said I'd never ever I never
thought and he says and he got to open
the night and he's thinking about it and
he comes on and the young actor says so
where have you been all day and he says
what I've been out all day and and
Kenny's punt no no pennies oh God
[Laughter]
print contracts and getting ripped off
by Wireless providers if we've learned
anything is that there's always a catch
so when I first heard that mint mobile
offers premium Wireless starting at just
15 bucks a month I thought what's the
catch but after talking to them using
the service it all made sense there
isn't one no meant mobile secret sauce
as if there are the first company to
sell wireless service online only they
cut out the cost of retail stores and
they pass those sweet savings directly
to you fantastic for anyone who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month what Billy said yeah mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying one for you or for your family
and admin family start at two lines all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
and high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mint Mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with your
existing contacts switch to Mid mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to macmobile.com that's
mintmobile.com
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
uh Johnny give us a voicemail
.com
here we go hi billion dumb my name is
Emily and I live in Winter Park Florida
my boyfriend showed me the Lord of the
Rings trilogy for the first time
recently and while I'm usually not a fan
of super long movies they are excellent
films I especially love the hobbits but
Pippin is my favorite my question for
you is if you could try any food item
from The Lord of the Rings what would it
be for me it would have to be Bilbo's
giant birthday cake and the magic limit
spread that fills up your tummy after
just one bite piggybacking off of that
what is each of your guys's favorite
meal of the day dessert counts too lots
of love and thanks in advance bye-bye
lovely Emily definitely not lovely voice
lovely well and a lovely choice of
Hobbit if you don't mind me well I
wasn't really in full agreement with
that one but so foods to eat I mean I
think just to have the magical feeling
of what the lambast bread does in terms
of filling you up that's exactly yeah
and then it feels like you've had a meal
just have that experience would be
interesting yeah and then outside of
that I get the feeling that when we
rested which in the book in Rivendell is
a long time yeah months and months if
not years in Rivendell I bet the elves
cook up some lovely uh delicate decadent
food you know I think yeah I totally
agree Lambert's bread you need to try it
to see what that is amazing and I I
think that's right that you would go for
the Elvish spent all day making
something beautiful I would like to have
the meal when we are dancing on the
table when um Legolas and Gimli have the
drinking competition what bar is that in
I can't remember now this is the third
movie or something but that place looks
like I bet they'd have a great stew and
a great beer yeah I would like to have
that meal yeah that's a good chance nice
lovely thanks that was a good one yeah
many more John
hi Billy and Dom I want kids with you
guys uh on Sunday at FedEx for Toronto
it was an amazing experience my name is
Perry I hope you guys remember me uh I
got a picture with you Billy my question
to you is uh I remember you speaking
with someone at Fan Expo about getting
your tattoo uh redone so what's the
story with that uh why did you get a
tattoo uh finished
right Perry well it was good to see
everyone in Toronto that was a great
convention all those conventions were so
much fun this year eh that was a real
real highlight of this year yeah and
Dom's got a lot more tattoos than me
I've only got the fellowship tattoo the
one that uh for people that don't know
the nine nine guys in the fellowship
except for John Rhys Davis who sent his
stuntman all got the number nine an
Elvish tattooed different places on our
bodies but the same tattoo as the number
nine in high Elvish and obviously it's
been 20 years since we've had that
tattoo and Dom was getting some of his
tattoos touched up and he said this is a
great tattoo artist you should get your
fellowship Mark Draven lovely Mark
Draven we should say hello to mark thank
you Mark thank you very much Mark said
he would he would be you know delighted
to tattoo any of the four Hobbits in
fact it was Sean Aston who did it first
Sean Aston got his wife's birthday I
think her name name for their
anniversary can I have a look at your
tattoo since it's healed yeah you ready
let's have a look
because it it wasn't that fairly the
largest has really faded oh it looks
brand new looks brand new we're not low
too short or we would yeah it looks like
everybody has shown it yeah I think
they've shown about now but I like the
little kind of shadowing that you've got
on it now
[Laughter]
it looks great it looks great yeah it's
much better I feel much fresher now
thanks again Mark Draven thanks guys if
you guys want a tattoo done check out
Mark Draven he's always at the
conventions and he managed to work on
myself Sean Aston and Billy and I think
he was gonna work with Elijah but he ran
out of time didn't he I wish Elijah
would just get all her faces tattooed on
him yeah Elijah's quite impressionable I
bet we could convince him across his
belly yeah I've been brilliant yeah
John is there another voicemail
hi billion Dom it's Daphne Sargent and I
want to know why what's your favorite
color and why
oh Daphne Daphne favorite color what an
adorable voice right hey let's guess how
old we think Daphne is
43 44 75. I bet in real life I bet
Daphne's
Seven Ten nice favorite color and why
um mine would be blue I think what what
Hue of blue
um
what
see like the blue at the back of that
hand almost like a
would it would it be a blue oh like a
like a sky is that only because that is
this guy yeah
darker than that well that's green
surely
but I don't know why I don't know why
it's my favorite color but I'm always
drawn yeah I keep buying the same thing
you know what I mean I'll go and buy a
shirt and then I'll you know a year
later go out and I'll look and I'll
think well that's a nice looking shot
and I basically bought the same shot
again I wonder if it complements your
your coloring your your skin tone I
don't think it's your eyes because I
also I've I bought a blue sofa
you did buy a blue sofa yeah I've slept
on that sofa L.A blue with your little
dog I like blue too I think Blue's my
favorite color mine would be an electric
blue oh blue electric blue what's the
color of your thumb like uh like a
kind of iridescent maybe almost
fluorescent electric blue something
that's kind of like Oh I like that blue
and in my as my years have gone on in my
in the last few years I'm more and more
drawn to Yellow
uh yeah I love a yellow they look quite
calming
reminds me of the morning you know like
a quiet morning lovely quiet and blue
and yellow goes very well together is
that right in a clothing Vibe and uh
anything right okay I'll keep that in
mind well lovely thanks Daphne thanks
Daphne we've got one more Billy
let's see here hi Billy and Dom this is
Kim from Leipzig in Germany and I have
two questions for you uh first one what
do you think makes a good director from
an actor's perspective so
how does a director have to approach
working with actors so that you enjoy
working with them and the second was for
Billy so I've read somewhere that you
were actually originally supposed to use
a West country English accent on a lot
of the Rings to match the other Hobbits
I'm quite glad this didn't happen but
I'm also curious
how would English Pippin have sounded
can you give us a glimpse so thank you
so much guys for making this podcast it
is always so much fun to listen to you
have fun bye thank you from germanism
where you were born Leipzig Leipzig uh
where I was born born in Berlin yeah
um well let's start with the first
question what makes a good director
right for me
um is it suitcases I can't suitcases I
like when you know a director said uh
once not to me but I heard them and he
was talking to I think a younger actor
or whatever and he says
what a director wants from an actor is
them to bring something even if it's
wrong what they hate is when you turn up
and say what is it you'd like me to do
they want something and I think a good
director once they've seen what you've
brought
then they're open to oh that I like what
you did there but could you tone down
this part yeah maybe it'd be great if
you sat down when you said that and so
they they get inspired by what the
actors are doing and then mold it from
there you know would it be fair to say
in terms of what you just said there
that it's kind of a collaborative thing
that's exactly what it is yeah my answer
is like you don't want an overwhelming
director who's just like it's this and
only this but you also don't want a
director to be like well do whatever you
wanted yeah you want to have a
conversation ongoing and then it's fun
and you're playing and that's the whole
thing isn't it and then you're making it
up yeah and then yeah yeah on the second
part yeah it's uh well it was kind of
true that we messed around with a lot of
stuff
um as we were trying to work out who the
hobbits were and there was the idea that
it'd be more like Mary
um Frodo is more RP so he's more kind of
posher kind of thing but it was as
simple as I think Pete thought I wasn't
as funny it and I lost a lot of the
comedy when I was doing that
maybe with the yeah so I wasn't as
probably loose with like trying to make
things funny and I suppose they they
needed a Pepin for well Pepin and Mary
to to do the the kind of comedy of the
or most of the comedy in the movie so it
was as simple as that but then also as
our dialect coaches rosheen and Andrew
explored
the worlds and the appendices and stuff
like that things started to come up that
lent to a Scottish tonality like took
bura you know the kind of idea and took
the Scottish word inventing Golf and all
this kind of stuff they live in their
own country and and nishaya they have
their own place they're in the north of
the Shire so there was a lot that it
made sense but you're right that
originally I think they thought with
most of kind of whenever anybody thinks
of Hobbits they think of that West
country sort of but also we wanted each
orbit to feel like their own character
we didn't want people just to see all
the hobbits so we're always trying how
can I be slightly different from the
other one so that really helped and as
well and uh I can't really remember the
West country accent how's it going hello
Frodo hello Frodo like speaking like a
farmer from Dorsey or something ah from
Dorsey yeah yeah but yeah so it would
have been it would have been different
but um
um as a as a as Scott as well I'm always
happy when I hear a Scottish voice
somewhere so you don't hear enough of
them what's that thing that they talk
about nowadays if you if you don't see
it you can't be it so this idea of
inclusion in in projects and stuff and
obviously there must have been a lot of
young or or even older Scottish people
out there going oh that's a voice that I
know that's a person that I could yeah
yes and stuff it's important the
inclusion thing yeah lovely lovely
questions to Germany I love Germany yeah
you've spent quite a lot of time in
Germany haven't you because you you were
singing with a with an orchestra yeah
yeah amazing was there a particular city
that you ended up liking the most I
probably and all my Times Gone to
Germany
I I love Munich I think you know that uh
that sort of would you call that Park
it's uh it's got a name doesn't it that
part of Germany
yes Bavarian isn't it I think I would
think I love that sort of oh yeah big
beers and we should go for Oktoberfest
and get absolutely slaughtered I would
love it Tom I love it I mean you and I
grew up drinking pints didn't we but in
Oktoberfest they'll serve you a glass of
beer that's like four or five pints and
you know why that was I found out at
October 1st I was at a place and you
know they do that real sort of designed
amazing mug with a lid on it and all
that yeah it was because to keep the
beer cold it was kept down in like a
cave in a Cellar so when you to go down
and get the beer was such a hassle so if
you're getting a pint do we do you half
an hour
so you got like five pints or whatever
that is so you can set for ages and have
a lid on it and yeah that whole city
just explodes with life during October
meet live music and costumes and you
know I think it's been tricky at times
to maybe
be proud to be German because of you
know what's going on in their history
but Oktoberfest is a time where German
people are like this is a great country
and
um it's a fantastic Festival great it's
one of my favorite countries it's a
country when I first started going that
I thought well yeah I'd like to go to
Germany but it's now became a place that
I think I could live there it's a place
that I could you know I like their style
of living all the different cities from
Berlin in the East and the West it's
just there yeah it's a great place yeah
the music coming out of Berlin and the
street art and the food yeah it's a
brilliant City Berlin yep lovely great
stuff thank you very much for that and
remember if you want to send in uh a
voicemail to ask a question or anything
and it's uh speakpay.com forward slash
the Friendship onion yes and also if
you'd like to send your fan art
we might still have time for you to send
fan art and at some point they're not
too distant feature will open it up and
it'll be an incredible thing can't wait
it's going to be a lot of fun
really what is it John Rob's here where
he's right there
yeah I've been here man I've been here
the whole time yeah yeah yeah did you
hear us doing all that stuff yeah yeah I
heard you guys the whole time very
selfish crime doesn't pay yeah I know
yeah we need to change our Behavior well
it's great to meet you I've never met I
know right yeah great to meet you yeah
he has we have an interesting story
about getting to know each other because
we I got to know you through your wife
that's right who will make this story
very short but I was in Australia
working uh on an X-Men film with Hugh
Jackman and the lovely yeah yeah the
lovely um dialect coach on that said to
me hey if if you want to like practice
your American accent you know let me
know so I spent like a few sessions with
him and he was excellent yeah and then
when I came out to LA I was doing a film
called the day and I reached out to him
and said I really need a dialect coach
as good as you and he said you have to
go with Sandy cordry who's the best so
great yeah yeah he's been he's he he was
her agent almost for the longest time
you know he would just uh if he he's
often busy with Hugh Jackman you know
and so he would give Sandy uh customers
and and it was great she she doesn't do
it that much anymore I'm sure she'd do
it for you oh wow yeah had to bang out
up uh yeah an accent Midwestern right so
we did I think probably I don't know
four or six sessions or something like
that and then at one point while we were
just chit-chatting she mentioned well
you know Robin and children's hospital
and I was like oh Children's Hospital I
love that show who's Rob oh that's right
Rob my husband and I went oh your
husband's in children's hospital she
went Rob is the clown the creator of
children's hospital I was like oh my God
kind of StarStruck and then within a
month or so I want to say you were odd
children the British version yeah yeah I
think it that might have even been that
episode episode largely inspired by get
getting to know you like I got a Brit
right all we need is like six more Brits
yeah
what happens in the episode it becomes
English all of a sudden yeah
the the you know how it was at a time
when all a lot of them successful
American television were adaptations of
British shows in the vein of like the
office right right so uh and there was a
couple of them running so we decided to
do it the opposite way like we were an
American show that the Brits decided to
do their version of and it was called
the hospital for children I think uh or
something like that yeah and it was it
was excellent it was one it's still one
of my favorite episodes the lovely
Francis Farmer was in there yes and
again I was a little bit Starstruck
which is amazing she was in Titanic so I
talked to air off about Titanic but what
a show I mean I was watching children's
hospital the other night knowing you
were coming in I love the fact that
right from the start you were doing
previously on children's hospital and
there wasn't a previously on Children
Hospital yeah yeah the Anarchy in that
show is I don't know why we started
doing that it's so funny because oh you
know why it's just a because because
Children's Hospital basically there
there are there is a story to it and
sometimes we challenge ourselves and do
like five have five stories rolling at
once but but it's really just a joke
machine gun like the plot is an engine
for jokes not vice versa yeah and uh and
so that was just a way to just have a
couple one-off jokes like this didn't
this doesn't have anything to do with
anything it's just a sort of satire of
previously on things and um
and also I think you know what I I I I
must have been inspired by Arrested
Development because they did the next
week on Arrested Development and it
wasn't anything that was going to be uh
next week so so we just did that reverse
basically so it's like half a ripoff
well how so we're gonna what we what
Billy and I love doing on this show is
we love trying to find out the origins
of people's stories because maybe
there's someone out there watching or
listening that thinks oh I'm kind of on
that path as well so we'd love to get
into that yeah with you Rob but just for
a moment there specifically talking
about children's hospital where did
where did that clown come from what is
that about the clown man uh
I don't know I really don't know I I
thought like
um
that I oh you know what I know a guy
this it must have been from my friend
Rob who uh I was in Boy Scouts with
growing up and he became he went to
clown college there was a college yeah
uh Ringling Brothers clown college and
he became the regional Ronald McDonald
so that was like the gig man he had hit
the big time and
and then he uh then he became then he
quit that when he when he or lost that
or whatever that ended and he started
just being a clown in hospitals going
over to hospitals and making really sick
children laugh right yeah and and I
thought that was beautiful until I
decided to make fun of it and I thought
well it wouldn't it be funny if there
was a a clown in a hospital who was
probably the least funny yeah person
there who is the most serious scary kind
of like had his head up his ass
uh a little bit more than everybody else
did because that was sort of the point
but um yeah yeah well I guess it's scary
people say I think people kind of get
off on saying they're afraid of clowns I
know there are some people that are
legitimately afraid of clowns yeah but
you are covered in blood a lot the clown
specifically so that was part of uh his
clown costume because he's a City clown
you see we had this whole mythology
behind the clowns there were it was a
separate uh race or even species all
together I can't even tell you if their
internal organs were the same as as ours
because uh and every once in a while in
the background every once in a while you
would see some of the background extras
they were clowns right and they were
sort of the they were a minority in
society so they were looked down upon
they weren't treated well there was uh
separate bathrooms at one point on
children's when it was convenient for us
and um
and then there was uh two types of
clowns City clowns and uh circus clowns
you know City clowns are sort of the
snobby ones and that's what he was
trying to pass you know and so this was
a whole lot we had a whole story in our
heads I don't know if that ever
translated people just go oh Patch Adams
right yeah like no no not at all never
saw it don't care about it heard it was
terrible and was was all that stuff
already there when you came up with the
show or was that something that kind of
you know as it went on you're like oh
it'd be really the clown yeah like the
history of the clothes another back yeah
the back I because I'm kind of a geek
about that stuff right you know I get
way too into that kind of thing
sometimes to the detriment of the show
itself and uh
um I from the very beginning we had
background extras as clowns and there'd
be sometimes a nurse who's a clown and
um but just scattered you know
um only here and there and uh
and I didn't want to hit it too hard
like we've only had out of out of seven
seasons of episodes probably two or
three clown-centric episodes it was I
just wanted just to be an accepted thing
nobody really mentions until it's
relevant
um and uh that's when it was it's most
successful but it was it was um I just
have so much fun doing that you know I
love mythology and it also it had some
of the best posters uh like billboard
posters that's the thing is like people
think I was the lead of children's
hospital I mean I created the show but I
was because I'm producing and sometimes
directing the show I'm not I I hated
acting on it yeah I just didn't like it
was too much time away from writing or
whatever and
um so I'm in I'm probably uh compared to
the other main characters a lesser a
more minor character and but it's just
an eye-catching thing on posters so of
course you're gonna have the clown front
and center you'd be stupid not to
absolutely yeah
um well let's go back maybe we'll go
back to the origins of children's
hospital but let's go back to like
how stuff all began for you in terms of
being in this business like when you
were a kid were you always wanting to be
an actor no I want to be a writer uh I I
never I didn't I come from a small
suburb of Boston and and I don't know
what it was like for you guys but in a
just normal Blue Collar middle class
town
being an actor is just not a thing you
know it was never we watched them and
they somebody must be doing it but it
was never I was told I could be
president someday but nah never an actor
um and uh it was not until my senior
year of high school when all the guys in
the theater theater group High School
theater group had graduated that I
started doing plays just because
uh I hated those guys they're nice guys
I actually know some of them now but
like uh I don't know it was it was a
girl thing yeah and uh I uh started
doing plays and I and I was told that I
was good so and when I got into college
I told my a roommate that I that I did
that and one day he came home I think I
was a sophomore in college he came home
and he was like Hey I signed us up for
uh torch song Trilogy auditions
and I was like great what's an audition
you know yeah and we got it and uh it
was then it never ended then I was just
like I was on the the road right and it
wasn't until the when I graduated I had
a
conference with my acting teacher like
the guru everybody has their Guru you
know this was mine Ed golden at UMass
and he said uh and I'm doing a perfect
Ed golden impersonation right now he
goes um so uh
do you think you want to do this for a
job
and I was like
yeah I'm I think I think I think I want
to do it he was like
yeah you can
I had permission and that was it and so
then once I once I am focused on
something I just put my nose down and
that's the main focus right so were you
at University near Boston then uh it's
like two hours outside of Boston it's
right sort of in the country and were
you study in theater or English or I
would studying English and I I took on
theater as a double major uh halfway
through college but only I had no plans
on finishing the major it was only so I
could get into the acting classes all
right yeah so it was sort of a scam
um and I kind of regret that now and
what was that what were the kind of
standout Productions that you're in that
you thought oh this is like I'm really
enjoying this well Shakespeare I I was
big into I discovered Shakespeare I was
cast in um Romeo and Juliet I played
Paris
in college and Community
Productions around my college I played
Paris three times so uh I had hair there
was a one one time I I make a perfect
Paris it's a art it's a tidy tidy part
um and then uh I did a couple more
Shakespeare I just got and then I
started focusing my English major on
drama on on on English drama like like
um modern and classic Shakespeare Tom
stopper you know Pinter I don't know if
Pinter's English is he yes yes he feels
English yeah yeah
that's English yeah
um and uh
yeah and uh then so so
that's sort of uh what I what I latched
and I did that the first
two years I was in New York City trying
you know like pounding the pavement I
just did crappy way the [ __ ] off
Broadway plays that nobody saw
and um and at that point were you
writing as well at the same time no see
at that point I was auditioning I would
start auditioning for everything because
I realized the one thing I wasn't good
at I wasn't confident about at least
uh was my auditioning skills and because
it's not something you can really learn
in college it has to be a practical
thing so I just went out on every
audition possible I got backstage
magazine which was the way to go back
then and and I went I mean I would go
for like you know uh
black uh handy uh capable
nursing student I was like that I'll
audition for that you know and and uh
and eventually I started to get stuff
and then I happened to get a comedy
uh sketch group I I auditioned into into
a sketch group bad sketch group they
were well-meaning uh they're very nice
people and uh and that that sort of
started me off on my next trajectory
and as a kid did you feel like you were
funny were you were you the funny were
you the class clown yeah I I well I mean
one of many I think everybody in Boston
thinks they're funny you know everything
yeah yeah everybody thinks like they
just say things in a funny way
like ah you kumquat is funny right all
of a sudden just because the way they
say it and you know they think they're
funny and it makes it funny yeah almost
so I didn't really know I was told that
I was funny by certain people
and then I was um I was talking about I
think it was like my boy scout uh Dan uh
group of boys I used to meet with once a
week Boy Scouts Cub Scouts and and they
and I I was going with my mother I said
I so uh um
uh Rob other Rob is the artsy one and uh
Josh is the sporty one and Derek's the
one that thinks he's funny but he's not
really that funny
and uh and my mother said well what are
you and uh and I said well if they say
I'm the funny one
they said they say I think I'm funny
um and she goes yeah you do think you're
funny
so I don't know I still don't know if I
was funny I I've seen the whole movies
and I was looked like a pretty serious
kid you know I I think there's a little
of both and then The Daily Show thing
how did that happen you was that based
on the comedy trip that you're in is
sort of I got I I wrote this sketch for
the comedy troupe where I was doing a
bunch of voices and characters in it
and that attracted a voice over casting
agent uh so that was my first foray into
the business and she used to bring me in
uh on radio ad auditions and I I started
getting some
and um
and then uh what was the question
how did how did it come about with The
Daily Show with the Daily Show yeah so
she so I was then in the UCB I went to
the I was in the UCB and and um I think
they saw me there they saw Ed Helms and
I there and
uh we um and then it just so happened
that the same casting director was
casting The Daily Show so she called me
in I don't know if they had called me or
she just said hey why don't you get in
on this and I knew I was a huge fan
already even from like the Craig
Kilbourne days and I knew I could do
that yeah
and so I I never practiced more for an
audition than than I did for the Daily
Show I even like took my sides and I
pasted them up on the wall so I was like
I was pretending it was a teleprompter
in a way and
and uh I was you know
making big choices and stuff and I got
all the way up to John
uh there's an audition with John at the
desk
and it was the first audition I can
honestly say I I had a blast on like I
just had a blast doing it he was very
kind of collaborative to him he's yeah
man yeah he and he's also like
uh easy with laughs he doesn't hold back
he's not Lauren Michaels who doesn't
laugh on purpose he's like he makes you
feel good right he makes you feel wanted
so
um it was just I felt like from the
minute they said
hey what do I want to come in for this
that it was right for me very cool
um yeah so that was uh that was how long
was that for I was on that show for four
years four years yeah was that New York
still yeah yeah and when you're watching
someone like Jon Stewart for four years
at such a close range yeah is it because
you've been lucky enough to work with
like Dwayne Johnson who again is is
another one another one of our very
important game joke writers
but like I mean the correlation between
those two is like the boat they were
both for a long time they're just
absolutely smashing in their particular
yeah field is there any is there
anything that you that you saw
similarities between those two people of
like well this is why they're both
hugely successful my gut reaction is uh
no not a thing except for maybe their
work ethic you know uh
they set themselves
up to succeed John came into the show
and he had already had a he was awake of
failed shows behind him and this was
sort of his last thing and he got in
there and he really
at to with great effort
um kind of changed the show into what he
thought it could be and
so so he made it into something that he
knew he could thrive in and uh
and and Dwayne like um you know he he
has he's very loyal he has um of course
he has his team of people that are with
him he has a hair person
she's lovely uh what did she do she
swiped sweat off his head just Buffs his
phone yeah maybe she maybe she you know
likes is
shaves Aaron patch here and there but uh
he you know he's got his team is always
with him so he I think he has set
himself up in a position where he he
feels supported and could just do what
he does you know and they're both I
wouldn't say John
I wouldn't say John John they they're
good with people
Dwayne you get the feeling that he
enjoys people right uh John Stewart's a
comedian right you know he enjoys people
as much as any comedian does what just
to say is he'd rather be alone right but
uh comedians uh but he's good you know
he's he's
uh he's he can connect he they know how
to connect yeah you know in a way that's
sort of elusive I that I can't really
explain I guess did you ever hang out in
Dwayne's gym yeah yeah yeah yeah oh what
the um the iron Paradise yeah only on
leg day right yeah going out on leg day
yeah yeah because I like to work hard
sure no you can see when I got cast on
that show I had a I was afraid I was
like Sandy what if what if he wants to
work out what if he's like she just
laughed at me like he's not gonna want
to work out with you dude he's gonna it
might lift you
he might bend you yeah he might work out
with you yeah but uh no he's no interest
in that that's his time that's I mean
watching him on Instagram do his
workouts he's just excited it's insane
he sells it too man yeah well he really
sells he really wants to I feel like
getting into the gym when I'm watching
him yeah you know and I don't yeah no he
goes he goes all out for everything like
you know try a little harder the energy
drink that he promotes the toe things oh
it's called Tower and then he has his oh
yeah
everything that he Associates himself
with he is a 110 involved like he's all
over it yeah absolutely I got crazy
respect for that guy I've been trying to
get Billy for years is now to shave his
head to shave his head to watch to watch
my all-time favorite TV show which is
the Larry Sanders show and I think Jon
Stewart in that is amazing he's great in
there he's amazing yeah he's great
because he's playing that very delicate
role of clearly they're trying to Usher
him in to replace Larry but he also kind
of likes Larry's yeah hey bud and Larry
is obviously super threat yeah do you
ever spend any time with Gary Shanley
never never had a chance to meet him
amazing yeah have you never because I
hear yeah he's just he was like a really
special dude yeah yeah yeah that uh
Apatow documentary about him I haven't
seen that oh it's great the Zen the Zen
Diaries of Gary Shannon yeah which is
like he was a big Buddhist and really
together yeah yeah I gotta see that I'm
interested in the with all these uh
shows the kind of American shows like
that is is it always a writing room
as they're always yeah that's always
going and always right I always like you
know like you were
um like the British like the officer
that would be two guys writing it and
they've written it and that's it they go
in and make it and then this American
thing which
which I think is is great for that fast
comedy like you were saying like machine
gun gags yeah like you it'd be almost
impo I I would be stressed out my mind
to have to go in and do a show with that
if I'm writing it it's tough with the
does the room make it easier well in
children's hospital we started using a
right we used to just Farm out episodes
for people to write and I would write a
lot and the other producers would write
a lot and uh we we we got a writer's
room I think after season five and
season five yeah it was just like the
last two seasons two or three seasons we
had a writer's room
and it was great you see why it works
um and you don't have to you can count
on things being worked on that you don't
have to be there working on them while
you're shooting the show but uh
but yeah it is a constant machine you
know when you have a writer's room
you're committing sort of to that that
sort of uh and I think it's also like it
keeps you busy at least for me as a
producer and writer and actor it keeps
me busy it makes me you know that saying
like if you want something done always
just ask a busy person yeah like I feel
like I can do anything when I'm going
going like that and is that what the
writing room is like yeah that's what it
feels like for me and the the the
dailies you'll have that as well yeah
they had oh my God so The Daily Show
writer's room was about 15 of the
smartest smart it's funny people you've
ever Yeah man so intimidating they're
going kind of minute to minute sometimes
because the news is changing always
going and then at one point when I was
there they were writing the book at the
same time so they were like burning the
candle on both ends and they were uh
super smart super funny intimidatingly
funny yeah that's when I actually
realized like because I was always
worried
um
that I'm of average intelligence I was
always worried that people would think
I'm dumb right so I think I sometimes
tried too hard to to appear smart
and that's where I learned to [ __ ] relax
you know because it's actually there's
some strength and some power in in
in surrounding yourself with people who
are smarter than you and being okay with
that not being the smartest guy in the
room and just now I just assume I'm not
the smartest guy in the room so it's a
I can it frees you up to ask questions
you know it it it changed me in a lot of
different ways so so with the top with a
topical show like The Daily Show
obviously they have to stay current to
what's going on at what point in the day
would you have to cut it off and say we
can't I'm right right before taping and
it's like
it's like uh and I'm talking like taping
would sometimes be delayed because the
whole show gets written and I don't know
their entire process I know they get
together and they're pitching stories
and they they're like this I got one
story all right we're gonna do that for
the day
um these two guys on this these two guys
on this these two guys on this and
they'll just be working all day on it
writing rewriting they get together with
John again in the middle of the day
he'll go over it give notes they'll get
back rewrite it and rewrite it again and
then at rehearsal we do it and we'll add
things maybe
and then between rehearsal and the show
he'll call uh the writers of the piece
into the room and if there's a
correspondent involved the correspondent
as well
and nine times out of ten that piece
that they're giving notes on will get
completely Rewritten before air
um before tape rather and uh it yeah
it's it's fascinating to watch I like
being just a one of the cogs in the
machine there and not the main guy that
would that would that job would I mean
it it's why he he retired it's like yeah
he killed him yeah he got gray so early
did you see that could you see the
pressure oh well not did he handle it
well yeah I don't know about the pre you
know I don't know if it was pressure I
think it was like his just life was all
this he had kids and a wife and
he um I was on the show as a guest on
the couch
uh a couple it was right after he
announced his retirement so he still had
a couple months to go yeah right and he
came into the the makeup room when I was
getting my makeup on and sat down and he
goes rob you uh you you're married you
have uh you have kids right I'm like
yeah he goes yeah and you take them you
get up uh and you take him to school
you're welcome to school and I'm like
yeah welcome to school and you and you
get them at the end of the day uh-huh
and then you you can go home you go home
and you have like you have dinner with
them
and basically you see the Sun at the
beginning of the day and you see the Sun
at the end of the day
I was like yeah yeah I see you know all
through the day yeah and he's like yeah
what is that like
see he was so ready right he was so
ready living for the job man I can't
imagine doing that job yeah that's
hectic and it's like we don't seem to
like know a lot about Jon Stewart right
like Leno was kind of the car guy and
Letterman was like the cigar guy what
did we know what was John Stewart's
thing I don't know I don't know if he's
got a thing outside of work I think just
what we I don't know if there is I don't
know I'm sure there is oh wait I know he
drums he's a drummer he and I think that
was
that may have started after he retired
from The Daily Show like he took up
drums wow and uh
from what my few conversations I've had
with him afterwards it seems to me like
he's boring as much energy into the
drugs as he did it in The Daily Show you
know what I mean like he's just that
kind of guy he's just death when he was
a stand-up he just did stand up and did
it you know
and uh and he's done some directing
right he's done so he likes directing
yeah he writes movies and directs them
and um
he's uh he I don't but I don't know what
his other things are I don't know if
he's I mean besides drumming I don't
know if he has Hobbies I know he's got
his farm yeah he's got a farm he he
rescues farm animals so he has cows
on that farm he told me he said you know
cows can I go yeah yeah I know him not
personally I'm not going to talk about
him behind their back but I know him
uh he set up
cows if you let them age which we don't
you know they can be the size of like
baby elephants you know they're huge uh
so so he's he's really into that whole
thing huge covenants
yeah I mean it's pretty interesting
let's see how big these are exactly oh
well that's a good thing to do with your
money have a whole bunch of land yeah
you're helping out like older animals
that you know yeah farm animals that are
just uh gonna be slaughtered I guess and
I don't know how he gets them but and he
also has he's his big cause is the vets
and right vets and 911 survivors uh
people that were working at the site
that was great stuff right that really
turns the show around I mean not even
around it the show was great before but
yeah that really
yeah George Bush was very good to us as
a president yeah yeah
some of those presidents are right yeah
yeah they make it easy sometimes oh yeah
yeah he's been very supportive 911 was
fantastic for us
so how do you go from that to writing
your own show and like how yeah how long
was Children's Hospital floating around
your head I think it was probably a year
I came here because I I moved to LA
when I got I got a sitcom like a
multi-camera sitcom it was uh Seth
MacFarlane's first live-action show
called The Winner
which in retrospect was a stupid thing
to name a show
because the critics are already like
yeah we're ready for that yeah even if
it sucks a little bit I'm gonna call it
a loser uh and um it that only made it
six episodes it was about a shut in
myself played by myself whose best
friend is a 14 year old boy and
I think Fox realized at about four or
five episodes in that that uh they were
writing potentially writing a show about
a pedophile oh dear so so that was gone
and then the writer strike happened and
I was poor as hell like I didn't have I
was I
add a new baby I lived in a new city I
had no job no prospects of even getting
a job in the near future because it was
a protracted the strike
and uh so what I did was I just spent my
time learning how to be productive yeah
for when the time came like how do you
organize your thoughts and how do you
get things done and I and I found uh
different ways that people different
like methods of getting things done and
I got my brain in order and I felt like
once my brain was in order
um
then my mind was sort of free to have
ideas ideas would just start popping up
and web series web series were a big
thing back then so uh at first the the
first season of children's hospital was
a web series my um daughter
uh when when they were young uh they
they have this thing called handmaid's
elbow
I believe and it's um your a ligament
comes out of place and it hurts them
really bad and they get Frozen like like
their arm gets frozen it's terrifying so
we brought them to the hospital and
and it was fine of course but I was
sitting there in Children's Hospital in
LA
and it was nuts there man scared parents
and there was literally a Life Flight
pilot
with a with a whole team pushing a
stretcher in like yelling stat like on
TV it reminded me of TV so I think
that's what got my brain going and and I
remember like this the the stretcher the
gurney was smaller than regular gurneys
and the IV bag was smaller and
everything was smaller and that really
destroyed me and I I said to myself
while I was in there like this is the
least funny place I've ever been in my
life and then
as we were pulling up to
my house home from the hospital I said
to Sandy like do you think this is a
good idea like I just on the way home I
had come up with this idea for
Children's Hospital like it
the most inner you know section all the
sexual politics of a
of a hospital drama but in a children's
hospital where it's the most
inappropriate place for it yeah it
really walked that Razor's Edge
oh well yeah now now I mean watch it
again I I'm I I cringe at some of the
stuff we were doing we were like right
on the edge there where we just made it
yeah I watched the pilot episode last
night uh the night before last and at
the end of that there's a little Talking
Heads with you when you talk about your
babysitter and I was like there's no way
oh I do that oh really I think I'd do
that Joe okay cool yeah yeah that's one
of my favorite jokes ever that's
brilliant it's not even in children's
hospital it's one of my favorite bits
we've ever done yeah your performance of
that is amazing but I was watching it
and I was like oh I just love like in
real time watching somebody realize
something uh like massive about
themselves yeah oh it's huge but what
did you mean
um
like you you learn how to put your head
in the right space but what were you
doing were you reading books yeah yeah
websites web like everybody's got their
every there's a whole little weird
corner of the internet devoted to
um being productive and I stumbled upon
this system called the get things done
GTD right and uh and and this one dude
Merlin man who had sort of modernized it
for the sort of digital age and and how
to use your phone and always have an
inbox basically so if you're walking
down the street and you have an idea or
you've realized you have to do something
and you say I'll remember it you're not
you might remember it but for sure it's
gonna be
it's going to be adding a level of
stress that you're probably not even
aware of right yeah so if you just get
it out of your head and get it down and
then there's a waste a boring way to
organize it and everything
um when you get everything onto one into
one place but uh
and it's also inbox zero is a big thing
I have like right now I have probably
five on red however many unread emails
and that that I I've how many of our
emails I've gotten since I've been here
there's a number of emails in my inbox
you know you never have like 300 emails
no no no no no right Billy's got 335
unread emails you can't delete them yeah
you can maybe something interesting I
did I deleted so much there's a thing
about big chosen yeah I probably deleted
something about because it's right I'm
sure there's a a treasure of of nonsense
I'd be interested in gone so that's
interesting though
working and you just thought I'm gonna
I'm gonna work on working and you didn't
think first thing is I'm going to write
something you just thought I'm gonna
work out how you work in the right heads
I wasn't even saying that wasn't even
the goal of like maybe that will help me
I found this system
and and I was and I
and I realized oh this will actually
free up my brain for ideas for whatever
you know whether it's writing or
anything and
um and it did it it really worked I love
it I do so there's I do a version of
that which I didn't even realize is kind
of similar to what you did but I always
say to my friends and I do it all the
time
if they're having a busy time in their
life or something's going on I always
say make a list if you read that list
man get it out of your brain and onto a
piece of paper because then you won't
need to like you said worry about the
fact that you've lost it in your brain
it's definitely on that piece of base
and it's the added benefit of already
having felt like you've done something
by writing it down so it actually gives
you a boost to to make a list yeah and
you know everybody likes to make a list
but there are list people and I was one
of them so this like really spoke to me
this whole thing and then the other one
which I'm sure you've done Rob if you
don't have any unread emails because I
don't either is
if you go into your little search box at
the top of your emails and write
unsubscribe it will bring up everything
that you can unsubscribe from yeah
really that's good no I didn't know that
correct so putting on subscribe and then
any opportunity for you to unsubscribe
it'll show up in your inbox that's smart
because like I uh I do that's one thing
I do get on I'll go on a on a
unsubscribe spree for a couple days and
then I'm cool for a while but then it
always builds up again it does yeah yeah
maybe I'll do another one yeah it's a
good one do one later billion Dom eat
the world
well should we eat the world William
yeah shall we um this is our favorite
part of the show Regular feature of the
show this is Adventure should we talk
about what you wanted us to eat which
are things quite interesting oh yeah
that's a good thing so I had what was
the first thing I said chicken's feet
wasn't there something before that oh
was there even though you were like shut
up you're not doing that wait but didn't
one of your kids say silk worms yes yeah
Marlo my my youngest daughter is like
loves she's like cool because she eats
bugs she'll eat like you know bugs and
chocolate or all right those things you
get a gift store yeah and uh
yeah because chicken feed is something
I've always been curious about but never
thought to order it in a like when I go
to a Mexican restaurant or something
because uh if I hate it and there's a
chance I'm gonna hate it how much meat
right I've gotta you know so it's gonna
be a whole waste of uh of a dish there
and so I never I've never tried it but
so then we landed on tripe have you had
tripe yeah what did you think so I had
tripe when I was a kid do you have you
had tripe I had that as a kid as well
yeah do they have it in Boston how did
they cook it no my dad they didn't
really have it in Boston my dad
um I was like a very adventurous eater
when I was young I used to like weird
things I used to try everything and
and my dad got such a kick out of it and
so it was like a point of Pride for me
and so he found this restaurant in New
Hampshire that their specialty was tripe
there was like um in our in a tomato
sauce or something and I was like great
let's go and I went there and I took one
bite of it and it's it's the lining of
cows
stomachs or intestines and it's
exactly what it tastes like it's
disgusting
uh it tastes like what it sounds tripe
trite and we we ate it like growing up
against Scotland really yeah it sounds
like a Scott Scotland thing right yeah
and the the cook and milk
and butter and
potatoes and onions
and it's actually the flavor of the
actual thing is is lovely until you have
to bite into that you have to touch it
with your mouth
it's like rubber it's a weird um well we
didn't find it so I don't even know why
we're talking about it it's an
incredible producer Johnny went to a few
times we went to him there's been
everywhere weird restaurants couldn't
get it anywhere well good but you've
found a packet of chips that were half
open yeah so you guys have a bucket you
guys have a bucket of garbage over there
yeah half of the stuff is edible first
of all there's like a light bulb in
there yeah and I found and it was all
stuff that I've had before and one thing
that was weird like they were like blue
potato chips uh or blue flavored
potatoes yeah they were flavored blue
yeah and then I found these These are
ruffled uh all dressed potato chips so
what does all dress mean or every flavor
you can I think I'm fairly sure that
it's kind of brilliant in a way they
just take the leftover dust from all
their other chips and they put it on
this chip and you can only really get
them in Canada they're a big Canadian
thing right
um and I remember for some reason seeing
them a lot in New Orleans
uh
and uh and you guys happen to have some
now of course this bag
it's half open it's it's
we settled on the bag and then we
noticed that the it's you know white
it's been one the the bottom of the bag
has been taped up yeah and almost looks
like surgical tape or something
we open it up and let's have a look
inside and I would say yeah I think it's
a worry that you're worried to be honest
and that it's it's sounding worse than
the tripe it's all flavors dust that's
left oh and someone's already opened it
Bob's a fan oh it's beautiful no they're
they're the best they're the best we
don't have a plate already
they're grape okay are you sure yeah 100
okay should we get little plates so we
can have a few
and now did you get these in Canada for
the first time I mean yeah were you
working in Canada what were you making
when you first had the ruffle all flavor
old rest what was I shooting yeah what
were you doing were you traveling back
in time and and I hope I think I was man
yeah because it was a shot in Vancouver
so I think it might have been hot tub
yeah that was a fun movie oh thanks man
that was so funny rely on you for some
info because we don't have any about
Ruffles I'm sure you can
do you like flavored chips
but I don't like the idea that it's like
an afterthought and I don't like the
idea someone's opened it you want there
to be more focused yeah and and fresher
I want it fresh yeah I don't want
somebody else's fingers
yeah oh no there's big fingers there's
definitely been fingers well it adds to
it hold on let's give it a little taste
it adds to the Dust
oh
now that's a Tangy chip quite good
actually bills got a lot of barbecue and
now a lot of barbecue I think you know
every chip uh is a little different too
sometimes you can taste the sour cream
oh yeah maybe the um cheddar and onion
uh the Tomato oh that's tomato as well
that's ketchup potato chips it's
complicated there's a lot of I taste the
ketchup a lot is it is it only Ruffles
that are allowed to do an old dresses I
don't think so no I think it's just a
type of Chip like sour cream and onion I
don't think they're as fresh as they
should be mom remember the crunch yeah
would this be one of the chip flavors
that do you have do you keep chips in
your house or you're no chips not
usually I mean I don't I don't Sandy
does the shopping so we have uh yes I
tend to subscribe to the idea that if
you bring it into your house 100 you're
gonna eat it so yeah that's to have none
of them yeah we have like uh um some
um what are tortilla chips often you
know just that those are it's about as
plain tortilla chips well they're nice I
like these chips
let's go on John this is quite
interesting oh okay
um
it's the flavor of mixture of uh ketchup
barbecue sauce barbecue sauce salt and
vinegar
um it was originated in Canada this is
where it came from uh now funny enough
Syracuse New York potato chip maker
Trails began selling all your all
dressed chips on their name Syracuse
style which is interesting because my
wife is from upstate New York and they
have uh uh everything
buffalo wings which is all the sauces
it's the best I know it sounds weird but
they mix all the sauces and they can
just glob it all over these and it's my
favorite uh it's too short but that's
about as interesting as it gets I'm
sorry I'm still well it's all right
so okay so you totally called it with
the tomato ketchup no cheddar and onion
no sour cream and onion in there no
thank you salt vinegar barbecue and the
barbecue for sure you've obviously got a
very complicated palette I've actually
really stuffed up right now so I I just
tasted a hint
uh I only uh felt the half the power of
those chips but that's a good chip
they're actually great interest Ruffles
does a great job I mean I'll tell you
what we we always mark them we give them
scores we oh yeah yeah three countries
there's three categories flavor of
course
for number one okay then Aesthetics how
does it look three how how useful is it
okay good how useful is a food how
useful is that like what would you do
like if someone came in your house oh
God Billy and you you would enter your
your cupboard and they said I'm hungry
and all you had was a bag of these you
see now a bag of flour eggs something
eggs it says the same thing everywhere
bottle of ketchup oh okay job chocolate
chips whatever I mean what would you do
uh yeah you know what I mean you'd open
them but I think people it might be
weird yeah I think it's kind of low on
everything but the taste scale right
well let's go taste first then out of 10
and you can have decimal points yeah all
right well what's a 10 I mean I'm sorry
a ten was like the 10th I've only done
two
okay now I've never done a ten a pint of
Guinness got ten for me okay flavor yeah
maybe you had marmite
if you like Marmite then yeah sure
that's a 10 on that it's absolutely I'm
not uh I I was that's yeah kind of
interesting it's in the quad test yes
sure is yeah
um but um Billy's not giving one
anything
yeah hold on I can't think because
that's an interesting flavor that and
see when you started listing them I
found it even more interesting I think
it's because I could buy it it was in my
mouth
and you were saying tomato and I could
taste it barbecue I could taste it so
I'm very I could taste it so it's an
interesting thing so I'm gonna give it
I'm gonna give it a for flavor I'm
giving a name yeah yeah when when this
initially started you you were quite
dismissive and snobby about this it was
mainly because of the surgical tape
around the bottom a little bit worried
about that yeah I'm still worried about
it I Love Your Capacity to change yeah
um I liked it too I'll uh I'll give it
an eight because it'll blow me away but
it was good I'd like it with maybe some
ranch yeah I I think you might put more
flavor just to chill out the flavor you
know like yeah I would I would probably
give it an eight as well maybe an eight
uh I'll give it an eight point one just
a little bit higher than an eight
because uh
yeah it's fantastic but it's still at
the end of the day uh or chip yeah so
it's still a chat it's just still a chip
and when he started listing off what
wasn't in the chip all the powder I
thought I was eating
I sort of tasted I I could um I could I
could see the seams and you know I could
see the like oh you don't like I don't
know now that we know how the sausage is
made no
um it's kind of uh maybe it maybe it's
lost a little bit of its luster I
definitely don't want to know how they
were made no no definitely all that all
that powder all through somebody's
sweeping up off the yeah we'll just
throw that I'm sure everything's above
board and then the lights the machine
that seals the bag is broken just get
some subjects
notice the difference well category two
Aesthetics aesthetic how does it look
well it looks like that yeah for a chip
yeah but Billy is ruffled
but also I don't like I don't like the
shade I don't like the color of that
either like and like piss orange I would
call that sorry it's not consistent
either it's pretty blotchy no it's very
it's not no I can't it's a it's a 3.5
it'd be under I like the ruffle
um I'll give it a four yeah that's what
I was gonna say right I was gonna say
four as well and then Billy's favorite
category is my favorite what's that oh
yeah if I had like say I was making a
soup would I sprinkle this on it oh like
a little see I was making say a pie or a
shepherd's pie you could put it in a
sandwich yeah
sandwich lovely Mayo with all those
flavors all right so that's that nice in
this sandwich what about could you could
you smash it up into a dust and then
maybe coat some chicken and fry that and
now you've got like will smash it up
into a dust and then sprinkle that dust
on a different chip and then you've got
to put on sour cream and onion chips
yeah wow with some red ranch dressing
yeah yeah there's something
I mean it's useful is it though is it I
don't know how I mean
if we
if you think about it that way there's
not a uh
a lot you could do with it yeah even
what we mentioned is not it's not great
a shitload of things I think a sandwich
is a good shout yeah
I would use them as um I think they'd be
great to dip into uh tuna salad lovely
you know right yeah just trying to think
of a different way that's a that's about
it yeah it's not the most useful it's
like all different flavor it's got that
cheese onion yeah barbecue and then
you're put you're putting fish on there
as well oh yeah
you're thinking it's extreme you know
the um
my dad used to eat uh chocolate ice
cream with potato chips plain potato
chips because it's a salty sweet thing
yeah I never got into it but these you
couldn't do that with no it's too too
it's too much already
that's a two for me a two I'll give a
I'm
a 4.8 for eight yeah four point eight
yeah well I'm definitely lower than a
five and I I think lower than a four I'm
gonna give it I'm gonna give it a three
five
um
3.575
3.575 yeah that's that's not quite
if you round up but um I like to do
everything with three decimal points me
too
I don't even understand decimal points
one decimal point in a
in a number right
can you can you no just one decimal yeah
all the way back yeah if you you can't
put two of those dots no no no no no
they're not real then it's chaos yeah
right I don't understand don't take us
down there no no no no no don't do that
well here comes Johnny so I found
possibly the person that sent these and
she has a question which is basically
these are called all dressed it's only
salt and vinegar ketchup and barbecue
she's wondering what your all dressed
flavors would be that's an interesting
question and it will take not to three
decimal points are we so three three
decibels three flavors you're allowed
and all dressed all right salt and
vinegar lovely jalapeno oh because I
love a spicy chip mmm and
so you've got salt you've got Spice yeah
I would go something like a lime chili
so now you've got a little bit of citrus
it's intense wow yeah that's quite good
yeah that's a crazy chip yeah
um I go ahead right uh cheese yeah
cheese chicken I'm gonna steal his
jalapeno because I like a little bit of
space right now and then hold on so
you've got spicy cheese spicy cheese and
then I'll probably have I probably
probably put the barbecue on there yeah
yeah I think barbecue is is the great
base so yeah yeah I go that those spicy
barbecue chips you know not the like
country Backyard Barbecue you've already
spicy like Kansas City or whatever makes
a spicy one I don't know uh yeah so
spicy that's the base
I hesitate to put salt and vinegar in
there because the vinegar is just really
it's overpowering you know it's going to
cut through too much so but I think you
might need that so with the spicy
spicy barbecue salt and vinegar
and sour cream and onion just because
that's intense too yeah very intense
flavors that's really yeah I think
that's I think that's a winner I love
that yeah John what was the name of the
lovely lady that sent in that question I
came from a few but that message was
from a Debbie P from Atlanta
and do you think
did she say did she open them and then
seal them with surgical tape yeah you
can send bags that are unopened I assume
right I don't know your policy here
they've been opened here I think you
pretty much have a closed container no
we would rather things yeah because you
know yeah I don't want fingers and
thumbs in there no just your own yeah no
no yeah somebody could be
well Rob it's been brilliant having you
on we've run out of time it's great
hanging out it's lovely to see you after
so long yeah for sure if you want to get
in touch you can get in touch with us on
our YouTube channel friendship onion or
you can rate review And subscribe and
leave messages and stuff you can get
hold of our merchandise at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com billion if
you want if you want us to eat something
in Billy and don't meet the world yeah
then send it but don't open it and then
seal it first just send it unopened all
right just glue it or so make it look
like it's not open
oh yeah same guys well same guys that
are a couple of the guys from children's
hospital and I are writing um uh
something new a comedy we know you know
I mean Dom can be funny if you need this
to be yeah all right we'll do a British
version brilliant Perfect all right
we'll see you guys next week see you
next week
[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your place the
baby you're my Pearl